700,000 deaths a year in Europe 95% hook
for for 25 years old smoky ones taken up
is a tough addiction to kick it easy to
see at this shop outside the parliament
in brussels the bottle no jungle our
killer guillotine coach logo tangential
merp and results every comin ova jared
mandela homologue nate a young people
were the target of tough new
anti-smoking laws they aim to reduce the
cool appeal of smoking by banning slim
and flavored cigarettes and for
seventy-five percent of packaging to
carry health warning menthol is and
husky fairly his product verse bottom
whose bong bong josh goot asana Kahlua
above and menthol cigarette mahal
Suzumiya mishra and get to see a tiffany
longer I ninety-four percent of smokers
start before the age of 25 which means
whatever the tobacco companies say they
have to target young people because
other people do not start smoking after
much delay the tobacco products
directive is facing the music at the
plenary but can em ep's pushed through
radical reforms or will the new
legislation go up in smoke one of the
big problems has been the lobbying by
the industry us the tobacco control
advocates what their resources are and
how much lobbying they've been doing I
think it's very easy just to point the
finger at us what we're doing is trying
to represent our business our consumers
and others to ensure that they're
balanced proposal is the outcome MEP
scanwell make up their mind from hearing
both sides of the other debate another
band of brothers lobbying hard as
supporters of electronic cigarettes who
don't want them classified as medicinal
sangle caffeine can keep your mother
monster not one of these products would
be approved and hundreds of thousands of
vapors would return to de backhoe on
Tuesday MEP voted despite gaining a big
majority the result was a mixed bag
regulation of e-cigarettes is off the
cards any pays unsupported to health
warnings sixty-five percent of packaging
but what it does mean is that the door
is open for a form to continue what
we've got is a halfway house we've got
Slim's on the market but we get rid of
the lipstick packages for example we get
rid of flavors that we have a phase-out
period for menthol we get warnings not
as big as I wanted but compared with
where we are now
it's a big step forward